hi guys welcome to Friday arees wow
these are things that happened to me
throughout the week like this and then
this oh this happened this what about
this guy back in Los Angeles the
greatest place on earth
Oh God dan caca don't forget loose ball
friend forever
oh my god it's behind the scenes of main
town oh my god it's behind the scenes
with beans Oh beans look at her go
named hound shirt that he's wearing what
what hello Flula bye now they know that
Flula is coming with us to the Boston
show members German impersonation he's
going to be a DJ at the show and so the
title is just becoming more and more
true it's gonna get weird y'all things
have developed hell yeah
yeah it wouldn't be a grace of mamrie
hang time if we weren't in some sort I
have to get your whole body oh yeah look
at this look at this
peach look how big have some other
messages
hi everyone whose dad is on the PGA Tour
and I'm like I want to be just like my
dad I've ransacked his closet put all
the stuff your dad is fat
[Music]
but not really but okay but beans can
cool subtle vlog their smell big yeah
you can't see it at all yeah yes
and then this it's Thursday night at
midnight which should be the time that
our @midnight show airs with my fish
cable provider whatever it is won't let
me watch it I'm so King angry right now
so I'm in my dressing room greenroom
waiting area at @midnight and we got oh
what hand that member also in their
green room dressing room that we've
decided that we are going to stay
private from each other until we tape
the show so that we don't influence any
of each other's jokes it'd be fun by the
time this goes up you'll have already
seen it so can't believe that happen
right and then this hello welcome to
more shooting of the secret project
don't tell anybody or spoiler spoiler
spoiler spoiler spoiler spoiler spoilers
and look who doesn't know he's abouts I
didn't do
your are the good things I can tell you
please might have tickets to may realize
it might get weird y'all show in Boston
we've announced our special guest Flula
DJ Flula would be live on stage with us
the whole time DJing really awesome
stuff that you guys I don't know if you
are ready for us jelly and then we have
at least possibly two to three other
special surprise guests are gonna be
announcing so so up your moist organs
because at we know one new and making a
scene it's going to get exciting
[Music]
[Music]
what